bitten mosquito-borne disease and you
mosquitoes as factors
mosquitoes are insects that live all
over the world
when a female mosquito lands on you and
bites you it drinks a small amount of
your blood human blood contains
essential nutrients mosquitoes need to
produce their eggs
the bite usually causes an itchy bump
and may produce an allergic reaction
importantly mosquitoes are also disease
vectors this means that they can carry
germs picked up from an infected person
or animal and spread the disease-causing
germs when they bite others
mosquito-borne diseases
common diseases that mosquitoes carry
include Chikungunya Dengue malaria West
Nile Virus and zika these germs infect a
person through a mosquito's bite and
then use the human hose to multiply
while this is happening the human host
often becomes sick
Dengue and malaria are all common in
tropical and subtropical regions of the
world but are rare in the United States
West Nile Virus and zika have become
more common in the United States mainly
infecting people during the summer
months
West Nile Virus is now the most
prevalent mosquito-borne illness in the
United States
while limited zika outbreaks have also
occurred in recent years
however it's important to note that the
mosquito species that carry each of
these diseases live throughout the
United States
search for more information on
medlineplus.gov about West Nile Virus
and zika virus
signs and symptoms of West Nile virus
West Nile virus symptoms can include
fever
headache
body aches
skin rashes
swollen lymph nodes generally
infection causes mild symptoms or no
symptoms at all
however older people and people with
weakened immune systems are at high risk
for severe symptoms
it is important to pay attention to
abnormal signs that may appear after
getting a mosquito bite if you think you
may have contracted West Nile Virus talk
to your doctor to get medical advice
about your health and potential
treatments
prevention and research
accurate reliable health information is
important for protecting you and your
family from mosquito bites and the
diseases they carry
search for more information about
mosquito bites on medlineplus.gov
there are a number of ways to help
prevent mosquito bites apply an
effective insect repellent
cover up your arms legs and feet while
outside
mosquito proof your home by using
screens on Windows avoid time outside
when mosquitoes are most active
specifically Dawn and dusk
and remove standing water where
mosquitoes can breed
mosquito-borne diseases are an ongoing
threat to Public Health
therefore doctors and researchers
continue to study these diseases to find
and develop better methods to prevent
and treat them
search for more information about
understanding medical research at
medlineplus.gov and explore
clinicaltrials.gov about trials on
mosquito-borne diseases
medlineplus offers trusted resources
about mosquito-borne diseases and how to
stay safe start with medlineplus.gov and
find trusted health information for you
the National Library of Medicine
produced this video